everyone welcome to my first recap of
the gibraltar battle of the sexes
uh this was game one i'm playing against
marcel ifromski from israel
international master rated 24-37
coming into this game i knew she was
going to play e4 um this is her her main
move
found a few hundred of her previous
tournament games in the database
and
i had a decision to make
more decision last night for me
what opening to choose
i'm glad i didn't play stafford i asked
her after the game
if she had prepared against it and
she told me that her friends were
telling her that i play a lot of staffer
gambits on stream and to be prepared for
it
um so i decided to play sicilian just
another playable opening a bit more
legitimate compared to the stafford
and after knight f3 i usually play e6 or
knight c6
but i decided to play a move i've never
played before
in
at least in a classical tournament is
move pawn d6 now d6
it's uh
it can lead to a lot of different things
and i don't want to reveal what i was
specifically preparing against d4
um which she didn't play um she played
an anti-sicilian bishop to b5 check
which is very trendy these days if she
did play d4 we would have had a more
maybe interesting opening battle
but uh opening battle turned out to be
quite interesting as well because we
went into
some of my main preparation
this is very very common way of playing
white is going for a marathi bind
structure
with eventual knight c3 and d4 has a
very solid reputation
i played this myself as white it's a
type of opening you can
play and it's hard to go too wrong now i
had looked at this
last night and this morning so i was
prepared for the next several moves
after knight f6
knight c3 g6
going for somewhat of a dragon setup d4
takes takes bishop g7
castling castling
and here my opponent played pawn to h3
now a few things to say about
the opening so far
first of all
at a very high level
white castling in this position is
considered slightly dubious as far as i
know
if white wants to play for more of an
advantage
it's more proper to play f3 first or
pairing bishop to e3
and of course preventing knight g4
after castling bishop e3 i don't know if
i want to get into all the nuances but
the gist of it is that white should play
in this way because after rook c8
b3
i don't have any immediate way to really
target the center
as we're going to see in the game
after castling castling
uh white has to
find a way to complete development here
bishop e3 still runs into knight g4
and the inclusion of like castling
actually slows white down a little bit
as we see in the game f3
i play rook c8 and white doesn't have
time for bishop e3 because the pawn is
attacked
opponent played b3
and this allowed a really cool move
which
i'll i'll admit i was out of preparation
at this point but i still knew kind of
the the general ideas
and it's very typical for black to try
and
tear down
white's
kind of central solid formation
and the main pawn breaks are either d5
or b5
and neither move looks playable here but
uh
i went ahead and played b5
after a bit of a think
and
we'll get into the the tactics of this
move but i do want to share another
tidbit of preparation because i think it
is interesting just to to see uh
what could have happened if white played
f3 here
then i would still play rook c8
and after b3 this is a position that's
been reached
over 100 times in master level play
and there's a very cool move for black
to play pawn d5
which just looks impossible when you
first glance with it white has a lot of
things attacking d5
but
this move is known just to equalize
completely
and i'm looking at the stats here after
the main move e takes d5
about 90 percent of the games end in
draws from this position
and the point for black is that after
knight takes d5
it's a temporary peace sacrifice of
course of white takes with the pawn we
take the knight
and if knight takes d5 there is a nice
move e6 and black is winning the back
the piece uh one of these knights are uh
are going to be lost
and uh it's completely fine position for
black and it's actually white who has to
play accurately to equalize here
bishop h6 was the main line
and i was prepared a few moves further
from here
but um this didn't happen the game
but hopefully it gives some background
into
the the type of position i was
anticipating
so after h3 rook c8 b3 and b5
i was feeling pretty good this is
exactly what i was kind of hoping for
out of the opening is to get
a position on my terms where i'm
the one kind of generating initiative
from early on
and to explain b5
uh even though white can take
potentially three different ways
it's a little bit awkward first of all
the pawn can't take because then i just
win the knight
if knight c takes b5 then i would win
this pawn and this would just be a
beneficial trade for me there was a line
queen f3 within d5 and i think black is
doing quite well here
if the other knight takes b5
then there's tactics along the diagonal
and i can take on e4
so the main point of this whole b5
break is to trade
a flank pawn for a center pawn
and i essentially forced that uh to
happen
and my opponent played an interesting
move
pawn e5 which i think is one of the
better ways to handle the position
because of course white doesn't want to
allow me to take on c4
so e5 was a way to give away the e pawn
force me to double my pawns and then
take on b5 the position transforms
into a very imbalanced situation
where after a6
knight moves back and then knight c6
white has
kind of the queen side majority i have
the kingside majority
but uh this pawn e5 is a little bit
awkward
however i thought i was doing quite well
here given that
i just have better pieces uh the knight
on a3 is going to have a hard time
coming back into the game there's still
some x-ray vision along the diagonal
and if we trade queens i'd be very happy
to take with knight
eventually go for e4 f5 knight c5 and i
thought this would be
a nice kind of queenless middle game to
play from the backside
so
my opponent here played bishop to e3
waiting for me to trade queens after
which white would just take over the
d-file
so i decided to avoid the queen trade
with queen f5 essentially just
improving my queen
and also preparing rook d8
and i realized here that
white's queen doesn't have a clear great
square to go to
for example um of course rook d is
coming if the queen goes to e2
then i'll have knight d4 to hit it
and if the wing goes to c2 which
happened in the game
then i have this move knight to b4
and
i was feeling quite good just given that
i i hit the queen
i essentially force white to trade
queens on f5
which uh makes my pawn structure a bit
funny now i have
adjacent double pawns
oh what we call this if the pawns were a
bit further advanced i would call it the
pawn cube but this is more a pawn
rectangle type thing and i know double
pawns have the reputation of sometimes
being weak but i think these are very
strong double pawns because they're not
easily attackable
and i can very
uh very possibly just advance and gain
more space
with uh with either f4 or e4 in the near
future
so here my opponent played knight to a4
which was i think called for given that
there's some kind of weak squares on the
queen side
white now has a threat of knight b6 but
also the threat of bishop to c5 now that
knight supports c5
and that would hit my knight and e7 pawn
so
at first i was thinking of just playing
rook b8 which looks like the most
natural move and this is probably what i
should have done although the move i
played i was still content with is rook
to c7
the point of this move is i keep the c7
pawn
defended
and in the vent of bishop c5
only my knight is attacked and here i
can play knight d3 with tempo
so uh i thought rook c7 was a bit more
useful
though this did allow white to play
bishop to b6 which happened
had to move the rook
and then bishop to a5 was played
and we got kind of a weird setup on a
file a file is almost completely
occupied
if only i could play rook a7 although
that would be a bit plunderous
but with bishop a5 it's it's very
logical for white to try and remove my
knight because nylon b4 has done a great
job so far of restricting this knife
from moving to c2
so
i didn't want to allow the train because
if i give white the chance to take and
after takes knight c2
white's knight can come back in the game
and it would be a bit easier to play
so i decided to retreat
but also attack the bishop
bishop moved to c3
and i kept initiative here with knight
e4 uh hitting the bishop
and also unleashing my bishop so now it
supports the pawn
and if white isn't careful here and
plays a move like knight c2
then tactics are just on my side i can
take
take and play e4 and white is already
losing material
given the beast is unleashed
the beast the beast is unleashed
the beast is unleashed on g7
i would win at least exchange here
so that didn't happen
uh opponent played bishop to b2
i control the d-file
and i'm gearing up for either the double
up or
the invasion with rook d2
so f3 was played
hitting the knight
and it is a question what my knight
should be doing in this position
however the drawback of f3 is it does
weaken
the g3 square so i
i went in knight g3 hitting the rook
and here my opponent delivered a counter
attack
rather than moving the rook
hit my rook
and now
the position gets really confusing
and i spent a lot of time here trying to
figure out what was going on
because there's a lot of different
options and
i was a bit perplexed
there's a lot of candid moves for black
i could take the rook
i could move my own rook
i could go in with rook d2 potentially
there's 92 check
so sometimes positions like this it can
be fun to kind of investigate the
various options
but it also can be very time consuming
and energy consuming
and after a long think i i didn't have
any like definite conclusions of
of what my approach should be and i
decided to play a move which i thought
just keeps the game going rook to c7
uh just
hitting uh aligning with the knight and
keeping initiative against white's rook
on f1
after the game my opponent told me that
she was more scared of
92 check
king f2 and then rook d2
which i'll admit i didn't really look at
so closely
but uh this looks like a fascinating
position given that i just leave my rook
hanging on b7 and i go for the
instant counter attack
against white second rank
and i'm very very tempted to turn on the
engine here uh maybe i will let's see
what does stalker say
wow stafford says black is better
but it's not clearly winning it's minus
.8 after knight takes b7
and then only move to keep advantage
knight f4 check
king to g1 i take on g2 king h1 rook
takes b2
black is down in exchange but has
a very good play for uh
yeah for being down to exchange
so
maybe if i if i calculated further i
would would have uh just considered that
more but that didn't happen i played
rook 2 c7
now i'm just remembering there was a
line i calculated during the game which
i do want to show because it was such a
beautiful line
and uh i thought there was a small
chance my opponent might stumble into it
uh but the line was
actually going back to
what was it
going back to the position after rook d8
i had calculated until mate in this
position
so after f3 knight g3
the calculation was rook d1
and
the variation
was rook d7
takes
takes
king h2 f4 knight c5
rook to
d2 and after bishop to c3
rook e2
knight takes a6
and this seems maybe like a random line
to calculate but i thought the the line
flowed very nicely and here there's a
beautiful shot for black to play the
move pawn e4
um just unleashing the bishop also
creating threats against the king side
and after bishop takes g7
during the game i only looked at king
digg's g7 realizing e takes f3 is also
winning here
but the line goes king g7 pawn digs pawn
and then knight to e5
with essentially the unstoppable threat
of knight f3
this is a main and one threat really
beautiful maiden one
and this was my fantasy during the game
uh i'm realizing now that white does
have the move h4
but stockfish is spitting out force mate
after knight g4
king to h3 and f5 and
white doesn't have a good defense
against this and this and the king is
just completely stuck
so
uh that would have been a really funny
line and fun line for me but
let's go back to the game
apologies for the the long tangent but
uh
it's a nice thing about like classical
slow chess is i i do have time to
calculate these very deep and
beautiful lines when uh when the
position allows for it
so
knight c5 was played um i play rook c7
and rook f2 d1
uh challenging the d-file
and now the issue for me is that i can't
play rook d7 and take over the d file
because i like control z7
so i have to find another move
and i play the move knight d4 thinking
that
okay why not just
improve the pieces uh improve the night
unleash the rook
and
create more tactical opportunities
especially on the king side with 92
check
ideas
now when i play this move i am
sacrificing the a6 pawn
so essentially i'm going all in i'm
giving away the pawn
with the hope that
the king side initiative
will work out in my favor and my
opponent took the pawn
which i
wasn't surprised about i was expecting
because it's still not entirely clear
how
black should continue the attack even
though it looks
it looks positive for black the knight
actually both knights are sidelined
and uh
i have time here to to try and generate
something
um the move i really wanted to play
during the game
was
rook to c6
to swing the rook over to g6 i thought
this would be a really nice maneuver
but i didn't end up playing this because
white hasn't moved knight before and
after rook g6
i didn't quite see what to do against
knight to d5
now i'm realizing
i do have the engine turned on here
engine's giving plus two for white so
apparently black has no attack even
though it looks scary engine's giving
knight b5 and looks like white can
probably force some trades with the pin
along the d-file
so probably good that i didn't go for
that
and instead after knight d4 96
i played the move rook a7 just trying to
keep initiative hit the nylon a6
and here my opponent played knight to b4
i'll admit that i made a very simple
oversight first of all i was expecting
the move knight c5
which
i thought would
would allow rook a8 and then i'll win
back a2 pawn or win
two pieces for the rook 200 pieces for
the rook
but the oversight i made is that after
knight b4
the knight defends a2
and i don't have the same
the same move to win the a pawn and
essentially here i uh
i'm down a pawn and i have to figure out
some way to get initiative
and came up with a move rook a to d7
which now doubles on the d-file
has a very clear threat of knight e2 or
knight takes f3 to discovered attack
win the rook on d1
so my opponent played king to f2
hitting my knight i defended with f4
and now bishop takes d4 was played
and
here i thought like in the moment
i thought
this was a mistake
because after takes
i'm essentially
taking over the d file and i thought i'm
guaranteed to either get rook d2
or just get a crushing initiative with
eventually e4
unleash the bishop
while white's pieces are really
misplaced on the queen side
it turns out here that
i completely mis-evaluated the situation
and white has a very precise line to
basically kill all my counter play
after rook takes d4
i played rook takes d4
and here
it is white to move
and
find the only move
which doesn't lose
and maybe i'll pose this as an exercise
to viewers i should do this more often
when there's cool tactics or cool
moments
yeah try and find the best move feel
free to pause the video
i'll go ahead and say if white plays
this move it's completely winning for
white
if white doesn't play this move it's
completely losing for white
so the only move and it's a prophylactic
move
is to prevent rook d2 with a move king
to e1
and
i saw this during the game and
i was still feeling good because i have
the move pawn e4
which i did eventually play
and this move
unleashes a bishop
so there's a situation if takes takes
and i i just win the rook because the
king's in check
because white can't take i i was looking
forward to getting pawn on e3
the problem is white plays a move rook
to d1
and unfortunately
i just run into
a complete
wall
white white has a very very solid
blockade
after rook takes z1
king takes e1 if i go ahead and play e3
it's really really close to winning
because the threat is e2 and bishop c3
and then
score the touchdown on e1
so if white wastes a move with
h4 just to show e2 keem d2 bishop's e3
and guaranteeing to queen
the problem with this line is
white has a simple move
knight to b5
and
there's no
bishop c3
and there's no way to make progress here
um even if i get upon d2
i can't effectively use my bishop to
attack the king on e1
because the c3 swear is controlled
and if i go and try and access this
diagonal in order to attack the king i
would have to move my knights
and when i move my knight i would lose a
pawn
so there's nothing to do here for black
and the a pawn's ready to run or the ski
pawn is ready to run so
i spent pretty much the remainder of my
time
i went from like seven minutes i thought
all the way down to below a minute here
and realized that
i'm in big trouble because we have to
trade rooks
uh there's no other
option for me to avoid the trade i was
hoping for a line like takes and
if rook takes then there's maybe some
there's some hope with after takes i
would have some check
threat and i'm also threatening this but
of course white can just take back
and uh again there's not much for me and
white has three connected pawns on the
queen side
so
after most of my time
evaporated
i decided to take on d1
king takes z1 and i played pawn f5
realizing that e3 didn't really do much
for me i wanted to leave some tension in
the position
i also had the idea of getting a pawn
cube with pawn e5
and not just for the lulls but pawn e5
would maybe have some idea of taking and
then eventually playing pawn to e4 yet
again but this was this was basically
just desperation at this point
opponent played knight to d5
and here
i really wanted to play e5
but i didn't because white just queens c
pawn
um if i if i allow pawn c5 my king is
just not in time
um actually it is in time after king f7
here here here here
i do control c8 the problem is knight c4
and there's no stopping knight b6 and
nca queen
so i realized that with about
15 seconds left and instead of playing
pawn e5 i played bishop e5
trying to at least control
the diagonal and stop white's future
pawns
but here my opponent played knight takes
e7
losing e pawn king f7
knight goes back to d5
i play king e6
and i will note that
the time control
was
we started with 90 minutes there was a
30 second increment
and on move 40
we would each get an extra half hour
uh we're on move 36 right now so i
needed to make
four more moves until i got extra half
hour but i was just living on the
increment
and after knight to b5
king d7 played this move with two
seconds left
knight c3 i let my time tick all the way
down
so one second and then i realized i had
one second in this position
and then tried to blitz out the move e3
but i was a little bit too slow and i
flagged
and it was game over uh white one
um now i wasn't too upset because the
position is just completely losing
uh i'm already down
what two pawns and there's just no way
to make progress on the king side even
though the pawns look pretty
uh what to do if i do play e3 then
white can very simply play knight to e2
now f4 is attacked if i move here then
i basically just tied down to f4 and
white is ready to start pushing the
queenside pawns
so my opponent actually played really
well from
what seemed to be a difficult middle
game position
kept chances alive and
unfortunately i wasn't able to find
the right moves in the critical moments
i'm gonna have to analyze this game a
bit deeper with engine because i'm not
exactly sure
what my losing mistake was
but it could have been like in this
moment with uh the night counter attack
um this was probably my biggest
opportunity
to play knight e2 and go for rook d2 and
go for the exchange sacrifice so
sometimes moments like this that can
make or break you
but overall i'm not too upset
i will say it was really refreshing to
play like an otb
classical game nice to move physical
pieces rather than just playing online
and uh yeah there's still nine more
games to go
uh wasn't the best day for the men's
team
if i just show real quick
so here are the standings from the first
day
as we see the women had the white pieces
and we see
some more wins for white
the overall score
is
what is it
for
six and a half to
three and a half
yeah six and a half three and a half
to the women hopefully my math is right
um it's been a long day for for me
um but yeah first round still nine games
to go
um tomorrow i will be playing
a well-known player and commentator
jovanka houska
from england so that should be a fun one
i'll have the white pieces so i do
encourage people to follow not just my
games
but the whole event in general it's a
really cool format i'll leave links
below to the official website
the chess results page for pairings and
standings
official broadcast on the jib chess
youtube channel
and stay tuned for more content